العقيد لايتون دعونا نلقي نظرة على هذا
البالون الذي أبلغ أورين عنه، إنه
بحجم ثلاث حافلات، وهذا ضخم
كما أشار أورين إلى أن الصين لديها أقمار صناعية
وهم يراقبون الولايات المتحدة طوال
الوقت، فما هذا الشيء الذي
تفعله الصين هنا
؟  أحد الأشياء الكبيرة التي
يمكن للصين أن تفعلها بهذا الأمر هو أنها
قد تجمع
معلومات استخباراتية عن الإشارات، وبعبارة أخرى، إنهم
ينظرون إلى حركة هواتفنا المحمولة
وينظرون إلى حركة الاتصالات اللاسلكية لدينا، إنهم
ينظرون إلى شبكات القيادة والسيطرة الحكومية
أه وكما أشار أورين
أه لدينا سلسلة من الصواريخ الباليستية الأساسية
لصوامع الصواريخ الباليستية في
مونتانا وفي داكوتا الشمالية ووايومنغ
أه، فهذه هي أنواع الأشياء التي
يمكن أن ينظروا إليها أيضًا أه
ربما ينظرون إلى الاستراتيجية
قواعد القاذفات التي لدينا في داكوتا، لذا
فهذا شيء أه كما تعلم
يمنحهم فرصة لزيادة
تغطية الأقمار الصناعية الخاصة بهم وهو بالتأكيد
نظام يمكنه جمع الكثير
من البيانات، لذلك هذا ما تقوله هو
أن هناك  هو المزيد من البيانات
وإشارات البيانات المحددة للهواتف المحمولة الاستخباراتية
التي لن يتمكنوا من الحصول على
طرق أخرى يمكنهم الحصول عليها من هذا
وفقط لتوضيح النقطة أنك
تتحدث عن أساس القاذفة الاستراتيجية هذا
أنا آسف أه المنشآت النووية  لقد
شوهد هذا فوق بيلينغز مونتانا
وكما يقول أورين، لا يوجد الكثير من الناس
هناك وهذا جزء من سبب
أهميتهم الاستراتيجية
للولايات المتحدة لترسانتنا النووية
وقاعدة القاذفات الاستراتيجية، أعني أن
هذا الموقع مهم للغاية  إنه أمر مهم
وأنت تعلم أنه جزء مما
نسميه ثالوثنا النووي الذي يتكون
من صواريخ قاذفات وغواصات، لذا فإن
جزأين من هذا الثالوث يقعان
مباشرة في مسار هذا البالون الصيني،
لذا
أعتقد أنني أشعر بالفضول سواء كنت  أعتقد أنه
ينبغي عليهم إسقاطها، أعني أنها
تطفو هناك فقط، أعني أنك تعلم
أن هذا سؤال حقيقي، لقد
قرروا عدم القيام بذلك في الوقت الحالي،
ما رأيك في ذلك
وأعلم أنك تعتقد أيضًا أن الصين قد  في
الواقع، لا تفعل ذلك من أجل
نفسها فحسب، بل من أجل بوتين،
نعم، في الواقع، هناك
تبادل استخباراتي قوي جدًا للعلاقة
بين الصين وروسيا، لذا فإن أحد
الأشياء التي يجب عليك النظر إليها عندما
يتعلق الأمر بهذا هو نوع
الدبلوماسية  أه فشل ذريع، إذا
أسقطتها بالفعل، فأنت تعلم أن هناك
احتمال أن يؤدي ذلك إلى زيادة التوترات
بشكل أكبر أه هناك احتمال
بالطبع أنك إذا أسقطتها كما تعلم
كما أشارت لورين أه سيكون هناك
احتمال  الخسائر في
الأرواح على الأرض أه، هذه هي
الأشياء التي يجب وزنها وإذا كانوا
يعتقدون أنهم يستطيعون التخفيف من
جهود التجميع وإذا كان بإمكانهم
جعلها بلا معنى نسبيًا أو
غير ضارة نسبيًا أه فعادةً ما
يختارون ترك أشياء مثل هذه تطير  انتهى
واه ودعهم ينتقلون إلى
معالجيهم